Go to 6:26 1:14 1:15, please. 6:26 1:14
1:15.
And then we're going to have a field day
with your Quran and its ahruf and its
qira'at. So, I hope you don't make that
mistake of talking about varying
readings cuz then you're going to
destroy the Quran and embarrass
>> [clears throat]
>> your prophet again. So, hope you're a
little smart in knowing what to say and
what not to say. I'm trying to help you.
So, now in 6:26 1:14,
6:26 1:14 of the Quran, chapter 6:26
1:14 to 1:15.
Okay. Read that for me.
Say, then it is other then is it other
than Allah I should seek as judge while
it is he who revealed to you the book
explained in detail?
And those to whom we previously gave the
scripture know that it is sent down from
your Lord in truth, so never be among
the doubters. All the way to 1:15.
And the word of your Lord has been
fulfilled in truth and in justice.
None can alter his words, and he is the
the hearing, the knowing.
>> Okay. None can do what?
None can alter his words.
>> Okay. Now, in the context, the words are
referring to what?
And the word of your Lord has been
fulfilled.
In the context, what is it about? What
what is it about?
Yeah, it says the word of your Lord has
been fulfilled. That's the context.
Okay. In the context, the word of the
Lord has been fulfilled. What is it a
reference to? What is the word? If I
have to spell it out, we're going to
have problems, buddy.
Kalimatu rabbik. Yeah, I know what the
Arabic
What is the word of your Lord?
The word of the That's the command of
the Lord.
You now see, this is why I said I warned
you, but you don't listen. I said, "If
you tap dance or lie or say something,
then again, you're going to leave me no
choice but to have to take it out on
your prophet, but you don't listen."
I'm going to read to you Ibn Do you know
Ibn Qayyim al-Jawziyya? Do you know who
he is?
No.
He is the student of Shaykh al-Islam Ibn
Taymiyyah.
Do you know Ibn Taymiyyah?
I think [clears throat] he's a tafsir
scholar, right?
>> Yeah, okay. Well, Ibn Taymiyyah, well, I
guess sorry. Anyway, Ibn Kathir was a
student of Ibn Taymiyyah, and Ibn Qayyim
Ibn al-Jawziyya was his other student.
And his Ighathat al-Lahfan, volume two,
sorry,
the noise in the background.
Let me tell you how the Muslim scholars
of this time, and this is about 700
years after the death of your prophet.
700 years later,
he's he's explaining the different views
of the Muslims regarding the Torah,
okay? He says there's one group that
says it's corrupted. That's the group
that you want to be part of. Another
group says there's only minor changes to
the Torah, minor,
very few minor changes, but basically we
have the Torah as it is. And another
group that says the Torah
can never be corrupted. And this is what
he says. I want to read it for you. Pay
attention. It's not Christian, it's not
Jewish scholars. This is Ibn Qayyim, the
student of Ibn Taymiyyah,
who's writing about 700 years after the
death of your prophet. Notice the verses
he's going to quote. One of them is 6:26
1:15, which you just read, which you
tried to limit to
the [clears throat] command of your
Lord. Okay, here it is.
On the other side, another party of the
Hadith and fiqh scholars said,
"These changes took place during its
interpretation, not during the process
of its revelation." Meaning they
misinterpreted the text. They didn't
change the text. They misinterpreted
during its interpretation. Now, watch
this. This is the view of Abi Abdallah
Muhammad bin Ismail al-Bukhari.
Al-Bukhari, who said in his Hadith
collection, "No one No one can corrupt
the text
by removing any of Allah's words from
his books, but they corrupted it by
misinterpreting it." Now, let me quote
al-Bukhari again. I know I know you know
who al-Bukhari is. Sahih al-Bukhari.
Okay.
He's quoting
Ibn Qayyim is quoting. This is what
al-Bukhari believed. "None of the books
of Allah have been changed. None of them
have been corrupted. They still remain.
They're still preserved." So, he quotes
him. "No one can corrupt the text by
removing any of Allah's words from his
books, but they corrupted it by
misinterpreting it." Al-Razi agrees with
this opinion.
So, al-Razi, another renowned
commentator of the Quran, agrees with
Bukhari's view. "None of the books of
Allah can be changed. None of them can
be corrupted." Now, let me go on and
see. He quotes the Hadith from Abu
Dawud.
Abu Dawud
narrated in his collection that Ibn Umar
Ibn Umar said, "A group of Jewish people
invited the messenger of Allah to our
house.
When he came, they asked him, 'O Abu
Qasim,
one of our men committed adultery with a
woman.
What is your judgment against him?' So,
they placed the pillow and asked the
messenger of Allah to to sit on it.
Then the messenger of Allah proceeded to
say, 'Bring me the Torah.' He didn't say
alleged Torah, like you keep saying.
'Bring me the Torah.' When they brought
it, he removed the pillow from
underneath him and placed the Torah on
it and said, 'I believe in you,'
the copy of the Torah, not the original.
The copy that the Jews gave him. 'I
believe in you and in the one who
revealed you.' Then said, 'Bring me one
of you
who have the most knowledge.' So, they
brought him a young man who told them
the story of the stoning. The scholars
said,
"If the Torah was corrupted,
like you believe, if the Torah was
corrupted, he would not have placed it
on the pillow, and he would not have
said,
'I believe in you and in the one who
revealed you.'" Finally, because this is
the verse that you just read.
This group of scholars also said, "Allah
said, 'And the word of your Lord has
been accomplished truly and justly.
There is none who can change his words.
He is the hearing, the knowing.'" And
the Torah is Allah's word. You see their
logic? Let me explain their logic just
in case you didn't get it. They read
chapter 6:26 1:15, which you read, which
says, "None can change the words of
Allah." And they said, "The Torah is the
word of Allah. Therefore, the Torah
cannot be changed. So, the Torah
remains. It's uncorrupt. It's pure. It's
preserved."
So, my question to you is
Go ahead. Yeah. What is it? Okay. So,
the part where the Prophet Muhammad
confirms that Torah and he puts it on
the pillow, right?
This We don't believe he is all-knowing.
He doesn't know everything about the
contents of everything. You better be
careful, buddy. Be careful because the
Hadith say, "Nothing but inspiration
comes from his mouth." He goes,
"Whatever comes from my mouth, nothing
but inspiration." So, you're saying your
prophet is a liar?
No, no. You have to understand what that
means. No, no. You don't You don't tell
me what it means, dude. You're not a
scholar. Please, stop these games. I
just read to you the scholars who
interpreted the way I'm interpreting it.
Did you remember that part? The scholars
said, "He would not have said this if
the Torah is corrupt." You mean these
scholars are idiots? They're waiting for
you to correct them?
All right. Let me let me deal with this.
So, when the scholars say this, those
scholars are not all-knowing either. But
you're not all-knowing.
Friend, you're not all-knowing. So, why
is your opinion better than theirs? And
what makes you smarter than them when
you're a young guy who don't know the
sciences of the Quran? And you didn't
even know who Ibn Qayyim was, let alone
Ibn Taymiyyah. And you're now sitting
judgment upon your own scholars?
Okay. All right. Stop interrupting me.
Let me just finish my point.
>> No, you can't finish your point if
you're going to lie, sir. No, buddy.
Buddy, you can't finish your point if
you're going to lie like this. The
scholars who know Arabic inside and out,
who know the sources,
Go ahead. Put your point out there. I'm
trying to help you stop embarrassing
your prophet.
As long as you don't embarrass your
prophet cuz that's my job to embarrass
him, not you. You're supposed to love
him, but go ahead.
So,
for example, when the Jewish lady fed
the prophet food, and she claimed if he
was a prophet, she wouldn't eat the
poisoned food. Didn't she claim this? Oh
my goodness. You're now destroying your
prophet.
Hey guys, are you hearing it? He's
destroying Muhammad. Good job. Keep Keep
talking. No, no. Keep talking cuz you're
recorded, and other Muslims are going to
hear this. Go ahead. Yeah.
Yeah, that's why we know he's not a
prophet. He's a son of Satan. But keep
going.
Yes, that's why he's not a prophet. He's
a son of Satan. But go ahead.
I just said it three times.
Yes, because he's not a prophet. He's a
son of Satan.
Now, when scholars try and read the
prophet's mind and say he wouldn't do
this,
they don't know. They don't know this
just like the Jewish lady didn't know
>> Okay. My friend, you understand what you
just did, right?
You know You know You know what you just
did, right? And I'm I think I got to
stop you from embarrassing your prophet.
The Jewish lady said, "If he ate the
poison, that would mean he's a false
prophet." You just agreed with her. He
ate the poison. You just condemned
Muhammad as a son of Satan.
The Jewish lady said,
"If you are a prophet, you would not eat
the poison." And then you said, "Did he
eat it?" Meaning she's right. He's not a
prophet, which is why he ate the poison.
You understand what you just did?
I don't
Yes, that's what I'm saying. How does
she
>> a prophet.
No, she knew that God No, no, no. Let me
explain to you your logic. No, no, no.
She knew that the true God would have
protected his prophet from being killed
by poison. The fact that he wasn't
protected means he's not a prophet. You
just proved her point. She He's a false
prophet, a son of Satan. You understand
what you just did, right?
So, what
So, was she backed up by scripture when
she said if he ate it or did she come up
with that in her own head?
>> Yes, because she knows that the true
prophet of God would be protected from
someone trying to poison him. And we
find that in Mark 16 and Acts 28. So,
let's not go to my Bible. I want you to
understand what you just did. See, you
you ended up embarrassing your prophet.
I don't want to bring my Bible into it
because yes, she was right in what she
said. She said, "If you are a true
prophet, then you would not eat the
poison." But he ate the poison and then
died from its effects, meaning she's
right. He isn't a true prophet and you
basically used that to show that
Muhammad doesn't know everything.
So, you are saying God's hand was forced
to listen to our prophet
>> trouble hearing and comprehending
arguments? Do you Do you have trouble
hearing and comprehend arguments?
I didn't say God's hand is forced. I'm
saying that's proof I'm saying that's
proof he's a false prophet because God
let him eat the poison to damn him to
hell, to die in a cursed death. But now
you change the subject. Let's come back
to the issue here. The scholars who
don't know the mind of Muhammad any
better than you do.
The scholars who don't know the mind of
Muhammad any better than you do, but
trust him when he said, "Nothing but
inspiration comes out of my mouth."
"Nothing but inspiration comes out of my
mouth." like he says in the Hadith. They
realized, "I don't need to know his mind
to know that his actions show
that if he honored the Torah, the Torah
must be the pure word of God. Otherwise,
Jibril or Allah would have told him,
'Don't honor it because why would Allah
have Muhammad honor a corrupt Torah that
no longer reflects the original Torah
given to Moses.' See, they were smarter
than you and they reasoned better than
you. Then they added 6:115.
Why are they wrong in 6:115? Why are
they wrong in 6:115? They just interpret
6:115 to say, "None of Allah's words can
be changed and the Torah is the word of
Allah."
All right, friend. You're embarrassing
your prophet. Let's go to another
subject. Cuz right here, I don't want
Honestly, for your sake
because this is recorded, I don't want
to get you to get upset with me.
I don't want to No, I don't want You
didn't let me talk. You interrupted me
every time I tried speaking. No, because
friend, I don't know if you understand.
When someone lies and tap dance, I'm
going to stop you. No, no, no. Don't use
that excuse because if I was having this
conversation with your prophet, he would
have beheaded me. At least I don't kill
you. I silence you to show you stop
lying cuz you're not going to get far
with your lies. But put that aside. Now,
let's come back to another issue cuz you
just embarrassed Muhammad.
I don't want you to embarrass Muhammad
anymore. I don't want I Let me embarrass
Muhammad. You're supposed to defend
Muhammad. Please. Muslim, don't
embarrass your prophet like this. I'm
the one who's supposed to do that.